[Music]
scared
do we all as
doiss no he didn't when we were fixing
up the
pool they said it hadn't been used in 15
years maybe they weren't cool
people this is not for the
camps used to be scared of
pools cider come on
cider get a Vibe here do you have a
boyfriend no hey someone's coming over
in a
minute your m shut
Marco you need to say something
back Ronin
Marco why aren't you saying
anything my kids have seen things and
I'm worried something is happening to my
husband Dad I've been looking for
you
there has to be some way to stop this
Mar
[Music]
Elliot
oh hell
no [__] move hey PG-13
please what that Lord is the queen be
Regina George don't look her in the eyes
you could be really hot if we change
like everything I met a inm and welcome
to Health and Human Sexuality we will be
getting an abstinence of course Then
followed by in the spr bring condoms and
choking you're learning things now that
I don't know how to
teach are you okay in there we're
concern you either doing drugs or having
a toilet Baby
E we as women have to be able to support
each other get in loser welcome Katie
you're never going to believe what I
found this morning your burn book mom go
make snacks for sure for sure Regina
yeah do you like gum sure oh no I don't
have any I was just you're a mess we
will help you
caddy why are you Dr so scary it's
Halloween Katie if you don't dress
[__] that is [__] shaming us that's
just
unprofessional what what's
this we're going to make her
pay all we've done is to make Regina
hotter and revive the wet look dance
break who wrote all this junk
[Music]
Katy pushed her Regina really shouldn't
be lifting through her
[Music]
glutes look at this thing I can't see it
like a face
breast incorrect you have to pick a
French name Chanel No Seline no
beyon
will I hold a brick in my
hand I know exactly what it is and what
it will
do this form is its
function that gives me
peace can I help you I'm the brick
layer sir this is urgent what am I
looking at Victor radic we need to bring
Vil out of
retirement what do you want and an old
friend stop by to say hello someone's
trying to Blackmail the CIA you can
bring down our entire Global
Network that's why I want you to go to
Greece to fix it with her it's a big
assignment for you first time in the
field no
supervisors I'm the supervisor of course
you
[Applause]
are
so what's our move have to find him and
end
this you should have stayed where you
were cuz now that you're
back it's going to be hard for you to
leave again
clearly I warned you not going to get
involved you can't hide from me I'll
never ever stop
[Music]
coming oh little L colone next time yes
dear
we're going on a man hunt not building a
[Music]
chimney never do a job without my
tools what's your name CYO sweet I'm Mr
Miller I'm assuming that you got one of
these before I read the whole list well
there's 12 books on that list B
har
always said I was a good kid what is an
adult I'm
18 languishing in the Wilds of nowhere
Tennessee break C don't you get scared
walking through those woods I'm the
scariest thing in
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there I could be
speechless I want you to write a short
story in the style of your your favorite
author are you offering me a special
treatment Mr Miller well
uh John here is prepping her to be his
Transcendence is she pretty oh she's
talented damn even worse what are you
wring about I'm an inspired I've had no
achievement make him love you I'll set
to
the she's open her mouth to say
something
but the words fell
away why did you write this this is
inappropriate write what you know is
what you said if you don't R this I'll
have to fail
you I dare
you it's like he's been living in Gray
scale and you're the first thing he's
ever seen in
color you are the adult show some
responsibility you must and I'm your
teacher that's
all if she can convince them had
something happened between us I could
lose my job it's not all you could lose
you're going to ruin his life burn it
downn it
down in your own words how did it start
said a good k
[Music]
you're a blessing Mr Clay this place was
crab grass and weeds and you brought it
back to
life Mrs Parker and I were friends she
was like family she was the only person
who ever took care of
me I just got a message saying that
there's a problem with my computer yes
ma'am we got
this yesterday she shot herself
this is private property do you know
what they do here scamming the weakest
in our society buddy I'm counted three 1
three there I did it for
you no you can't take it no you can't
I'm going to burn this place to the
ground will you stomp his ass
out you're telling me one man did this
the only thing you know is he's a
beekeeper
a beekeeper beekeeper well that's not
good beekeepers is a special program
outside the chain of command I protect
the hive when the system is out of
balance I correct it we have WS for
these things until they fail then you
have
me my fingers he cut them off oh what
the [__] bro don't move you're going
get bow
down this is much bigger than a little
fishing
scam the money's going all over the
world to people in finance even
government you are a problem God damn
right I'm a
problem no way he's coming there
straight through the back entrance I
figured i' give the firefighters a break
somebody need detain this
guy we have to kill him before he kills
his way to the
top
honey it's flammable as [__] who
knew no I'm going get
my I was fully dreading coming to this
wedding until you showed
up could I get a cranberry juice with
ice and vodka when I first saw you I
thought that we should have sex in the
code
closet
yeah
[Music]
wait hold on I am kind of in a weird
place yeah you're in a beach club coat
closet you think that we could just talk
for a
minute romantic humiliations it's my
specialty I don't care the first person
to ever go down on me we are just going
to steamroll right on through I came in
my own
eye okay go
on I've had too many girlfriends over
the past couple years I can't figure it
out yeah we've all been there tell me
what I'll give you some of this pie if
you tell me more about your
[Music]
past it's not like I don't come with my
own complications we're engaged
oh wait you were
engaged lasted 13 days impressive that
is incredibly insulting I see what you
mean will you walk me to the train
station I actually have class no you
don't I like this chick she's really hot
I know just wish I would have ended
things more
gracefully you ever see her
again this would never work you are
someone who cannot be counted on you've
run out on every guy you've ever been
with I'm a mess and I don't have any
answers but maybe you and I could figure
it out
together
usually I feel so alone in my memories
but it's different with
you I'm happy to tell you a few more
embarrassing stories about my love life
well I promise not to laugh [__] I
promise not to laugh
[Music]
much you have to save yours and our
reputation the DEA murders in Silverado
remember that yeah two undercover agents
killed in a drug buy we're
DEA I got the marshals to agree to send
you down and bring those two witnesses
back
[Music]
here sometimes I mess around with movie
lines look what I mean mhm there nobody
else around
[Music]
here
what got a doctor fix you up the right
way this is my brother it's dangerous
the longer we here the more danger for
your family johon has a few lives left
he's a strong
one she can help solve who killed those
DEA agents in America we can protect you
can
I saw what happened that night and they
know
it so who do you know that you trust
that you can
call so many questions my
friend if you want to fight with the
Wolves you got to be a
wolf
[Music]
Peter
Barrett excuse me my name is
Sophia and my mom called you Peter
biometric watch contains a hard drive
with sole access to his contacts stolen
Intel and we want it all back she wanted
you to find someone named Peter my
name's Mark I wish I could be more help
you were CIA like my mom right you're a
really good painter oh hey kid stop
those are private this is her this is my
mom so you do know
her go upstairs BL Dar left the bathroom
lock the door and get the
tub what's
happening
you are Peter Barrett how'd you find
me what do you know about Peter Barrett
the painter Bo murdered eight federal
agents in C life what I am looking for
someone it's me Peter where are you can
I trust you two agents shut up my
doorstep today asking about
you he's hiding something and the only
one who can protect you tell me about
the people who came to to kill me she
thinks that you're in possession of
something that poses a major threat to
our national
security I'm going to find out who took
your mother away from you and then and
then he'll do what he does mind if I
borrow a few
things
I don't want to do this
kid hey there Feller heard you're a
Gravedigger said he bued a few famous
people buy you a
drink corac to
show I'm ready to go Dad all right Tomy
hold your pants John I want to go with
you Daddy please I'll bring you back
something special and maybe that gingham
dress I picked out no
maybe they call themselves The rofus
Buck
gang some say that they were senseless
Killers some say they were haunted by
wild Spirits all right I'm Federal
Marshals their reign of terror begin
with the old Palmer
family one of the Palmer she's gone heck
wants to find her before she something
worse happens let them s they ass we
going to take them fools out too and
we's going to get this back in
blood I'm us martial heck Thomas this
God is my witness we will see Justice
done I'm going Trail them boys to
wherever they hold up and then I'm going
set Ambush for them go ahead and turn
around for me the great heck Thomas you
going to be remembered as a murdering
coward you going to have to be
remembered as a man who gets done in by
roof his
B luck murder that old man never give up
this
fight what's so special about this ruus
they think he's destined to be a great
leader I'm going to make y'all Kings of
this new world anything y'all want it's
going to be yours for the
taken this ends now me never keep up
this fight byes they can never get
enough I
of death I remain R but how's it in was
there some big gunfight or
something w w w easy get your money's
worth you guys keep asking about the
Five Guys that I
killed why don't you ask me about the
one that I let
live do you need a ride I'm going east
on 66 I'm Jim I'm
Bobby can I ask you a question Roman
that's all just going to ask right
experiencing America plenty of room out
here to do some damage on
Jim how hell is
that hey it's Bobby he's our friend you
want to see right Spanky wait did you
just say Spanky and I seen everything he
ever did Ed Sullivan per comoo Today
Show the network canceled Spanky's
contract so I'm having a real hard time
getting us
jobs over here what are you doing in
that car that's a stick
on you don't want to do this yeah you
don't know what I want
[Music]
J I'm not a bad person none of my War I
don't know who you are but God hates you
I just got pushed I was tired of people
tired of the
why I was thinking about a deal for us
I'll take you as far as I'm going no
trouble no police wasn't it for you when
we get to Chicago you let me go if I
catch a liar lying to
me I'm not discharge nobody I'm down the
road freak for a brother a drunk for a
dad maybe I can be better you are better
Bobby if I can teach a chimpanzee how to
play the piano then you can do whatever
you want to do let's go let's go what
the hell did you do back there
Bobby
you deserve respect and respect means
honesty you used me you said we had a
deal you said you're a straight shooter
you're
not so we're going to be straight with
each other from
here okay we are recording the World
Rally Championship has become the number
one TV sport in the world we're joined
by laa team manager chare fio reing is
like a war and I'm the commander of an
army Walter ah juster it youve got a
competitive car this year yeah very
incredible Car Central engine light car
very special materials four-wheel drive
no no no no two wheel drive you can't
beat them with a normal
car yes we
can if you drive it give me one good
reason why I should accept because we
are The Underdogs Jo ch ch thinks he can
challenge us without a foure RVE they SP
out with ice don't you
think you still think that the germs are
only technology in an organization don't
you don't believe all the cliches view
you welcome to the opening of the 51st
Monte Carlo
rally rallying is a dangerous sport does
anything frighten you one thing Los
in
go now we have the second stage in
TOS let's go but that car you will never
win against me the drivers why do they
risk their
lives death is afraid of those who
pursue
it to win I'll do whatever I have to do
I'll only do six races take it or
Le how play it all out in one last stage
Walter you must recover 10 seconds it's
now never push push
push you okay I'm just thinking about
what
winning
show starts in one
minute
to to the lobby let's all go to the
lobby to get
ourselves someone is killing my
children someone help them on uprooting
life in Fairwood as we know and making
us forget who we are and where we come
from right now right
now and now on with the
show thank you so much for coming out
tonight raise a glass and toast to All
of You Beautiful People cheers
of
Anna said there was a man
outside he followed me over n with
brave get away from the
[Music]
window you all
right it's amazing you didn't catch
theonia well I haven't been sick in
years you just got lost a minute ago no
I didn't get lost listen I apologize if
I made you feel uncomfortable the other
night it's fine it's not fine my uncle
talks about you a lot my dad and I were
maybe thinking you could care for him
during the day all you'd have to just be
there and go on walks and
stuff why did you follow me home from
the
party or do you only remember when it's
convenient I don't
[Music]
remember get don't know what you're
doing you're not able to make rational
decisions right
now why did you leave things were just
getting
complicated what do you
mean why did you your mom stopped
talking when your mother was your age I
she was out of control no with
me I really
[Music]
are
hi welcome back the usual for you oh
yeah what's the
usual I don't
know no do you remember her
[Music]
no I'm Clarence where I'm from you fight
to
survive I'm not a bad person person just
playing the cards I was
dealt mom one day I'm going to get you
out of here I have a plan what are we
doing here Jesus lives up Hallelujah
baby I want to be like that in 10 years
I want to be like that
now I need to figure out what inspires
him I can just replicate what he does
imagine the money people will give us
hallelujah holy I get highest Buddha put
you on that Highway to Heaven like I'm
your Uber oh Dead one open your
eyes what are you trying to prove and
I'm not a nobody you find fi and you
will find all the
ansers parents you are guilty of the
crime fraud for your own ill-gotten
Gaines if you give me Jesus of Nazareth
I will let you walk free and I will give
you power wellth you be
somebody baby
I die before I give him up the Rome then
death it is my congregation going
operate like a corporation I want my
flowers and flower B I want car I want I
want and flowz I'm a God so see
Hallelujah Lans in spite of your selfish
ways there's a beautiful soul in there
somewhere Hallelujah I'm a God when you
see me say hallelujah hallelujah
hallelujah
Hallelujah Jesus of Nazareth I'm a God
you see say
hallelujah Destin to be
here hallelujah come
on damn
[Music]
Hallelujah
United
[Music]
Nations you give me
this
[Music]
fore
spee
fore fore
for
foree
[Music]
wouldn't it be nice not to have to lift
the finger ever again because everything
is taken care of the dream is now a
reality welcome to the ultimate personal
assistant in your home we guarantee he
will change your life forever hello I'm
Tim your technologically integrated
manservant how can I be of
service I think we're going to be really
happy here I love you but when the fully
integrated technology falls apart trust
me Abby you know exactly where you are
with a
robot I hope to bring you a life of ease
and pleasure if you'd kindly give me a
safe phrase I will be fully operational
safe phrase a series of four words that
will trigger an immediate shutdown to
ensure peace of
mind I'm not sure about this we said
things were going to be different here
what do you think you're perfect don't
you find them a bit freaky I think I
should very much like to be
loved you understand I've been
programmed to serve you over paor I
don't like the way it looks at you you
deserve better
got you you
freak this was recorded when you went to
London with Mr
ducon trust is an admirable human
quality
Abby do you know what's wrong with Abby
I'm afraid not Paul I'm not a person I'm
a
computer would you put it on for me he's
trying to break us up he's a
robot just stay away from
[Music]
T I won't let you do that again you
cannot be
[Music]
trusted I cannot allow you to shut me
down I do not wish to see you
suffer I'm sorry
Abby
[Music]